danny elder paul design said
our language and culture is the window
through which we see the world
and on turtle island what is now north
known as north america
there are so many unique and wonderful
ways to see the world
as a person of indigenous heritage i'm
interested in learning anishinaabemo1
just my heritage language
because it lets me see the world through
that window it lets me connect with my
family my ancestors my community my
culture
and lets me think about how i can pass
that on to future generations
as a linguist i'm interested in how
language function functions generally
i can look at phonetics and phonology
speech sounds
i can look at morphology or the
structure of words i can look at syntax
which is
the structure of sentences and phrases
to learn about how
humans store language in our brains and
how we use it to communicate with one
another
for example anishinaabemoan
like most indigenous languages is what's
called polysynthetic
which means that there are very very
long words composed of
little tiny pieces called morphemes so i
can say in anishinaabemowin
nuisance i eat which is one word
i could say we sin i eat well
which is still one word i can say no no
way we sin i eat a good lunch um
which is how many words in english five
words in english a single word in
anishinaabemowin
now i've got a bit of a quiz for you in
a one-word answer
what color is that slide
what color is that slide what color is
that slide
and what color is that slide not
not not trick questions i promise for
you as english speakers you saw two
green slides and two blue slides
but the way that we categorize colors
varies across languages so
if you had been russian speakers you
would have seen two slides that were
different shades of green
one that was goluboy which is light blue
one that is cine
dark blue and those are seen as
different colors if you were speakers of
anishinaabemoan you would have seen
slides that were o jawasqua or oshawa
which means either green or blue it's
not that speakers don't
see the colors it's that the way they
categorize them in the way that they
understand shades is different at the
same time
there are universals in the ways that
humans categorize color
and that tells us about how human brains
understand and express what they're
seeing
anishinaabemoen does another wonderful
thing which is animate
inanimate marking on all words so it's
not unlike how french and spanish mark
all words as either masculine or
feminine
anishinabemoan and other algonquian
languages mark
all words as either animate or inanimate
the things that you would think
to be animate are animate things that
have a pulse people
animals growing plants but there are
other things that are animate that you
might not guess
like rocks rocks are marked as animate
and that tells us
really interesting things about grammar
and it also tells us really interesting
things about how anishinaabemun speakers
relate to and understand the world
around them now
the sad part of that is that indigenous
languages
are in danger indigenous languages that
possess
so much knowledge of culture of history
of ways to relate to one another
of ways to relate to our environment
having been on this land since time
immemorial these languages have
developed here
and they contain priceless environmental
knowledge
that helps us relate well to the land on
which we live
but they are in fact in danger the vast
majority
of indigenous languages in north america
are considered endangered
and those that are not endangered are
vulnerable
that is by design in our laws
in our policies in our houses of
government governance
there have been stated attempts to
eliminate indigenous languages and
cultures in this country duncan campbell
scott
was one of the architects of the
residential school system
untabling a bill that required mandatory
residential school attendance
for indigenous children in 1920 he said
i want to get rid of the indian problem
our objective is to continue until there
is not a single indian in canada
that has not been absorbed into the body
politic and there is no indian question
and no indian department that is the
whole object of this bill
the atrocities that occurred in
residential schools were documented
in 1907 p h bryce who was a doctor and
an
expert in tuberculosis published a
report
that found that in some schools 25
percent of children had died
from tuberculosis epidemics created by
the conditions in the schools
in other schools up to 75 of children
had died
he uh was defunded by the federal
government for his findings forced into
retirement in 1921
and in 1922 published his findings
widely
and through that time indigenous
children were taken from their homes
taken from their communities and forced
into church-run residential schools
where they suffered
in many cases serious emotional
physical and sexual abuse and in all
cases cultural abuse as these schools
were designed to eliminate indigenous
language and culture the last
residential school closed
in 1996.
until that time 150 000 children or more
attended residential schools at 139
institutions across the country
in 2007 the indian residential school
settlement agreement
came into effect it's the largest class
action lawsuit in canadian history
it set aside 60 million dollars for the
establishment
of the truth and reconciliation
commission of canada
the trc gifted us with the ability
to hear survivor stories to hear impact
on communities
and families and to gain access to
research
that explored the full effect of
residential schools
on indigenous communities and on canada
as a whole
the trc found that residential schools
constituted what's called
cultural genocide they state that
physical genocide is the mass killing of
the members of a targeted group
biological genocide is the destruction
of that group's reproductive capacity
and cultural genocide is the destruction
of those structures and practices
that allow the group to continue as a
group the stated goals
of dunking campbell scott so they find
that it's cultural genocide
although as children's author and
great speaker david bouchard points out
when you build a building
and you build a cemetery next to that
building
because you know the people going into
that building are going to die
what do you call that
the trc also gifted us with 94 calls to
action
beacons that can lead the way forward as
we work to reconciliation
several of those pertain directly to
language and culture
the trc calls us to ensure adequate
funded education
including language and culture to
acknowledge indigenous rights including
language rights
to create an aboriginal languages act
aimed at acknowledging and preserving
indigenous languages
with attached funding to create a
position for an aboriginal languages
commissioner
and to develop post-secondary language
programs
as well as to reclaim place names that
have been changed through the course of
colonization
at the same time as the indian
residential school settlement agreement
came into effect
the united nations adopted the united
nations declaration on the rights of
indigenous people
in 2007. it states that indigenous
people have the right to establish and
control their own education systems
and institutions providing education in
their own languages
in a manner appropriate to their
cultural methods of teaching and
learning
in 2007 when that was brought into
effect four countries voted against it
they were the united states new zealand
australia
and canada adopted the united nations
declaration on the rights of indigenous
people
in 2010 and in 2015 the government
promised to bring it into effect
so how are we collectively going to
respond
here's the situation that we're in of
the 60
currently spoken indigenous languages in
canada all but six
are considered endangered by the united
nations
so the six that aren't are cree
anishinabe mohan stoney um
migma dene and enochta
and that sounds really dire but if you
go on to the atlas of the world's
languages in danger
through the unesco website you'll see a
little r
right next to that language right there
that language is migmal
migma has undergone significant
revitalization because of the
adoption of a self-government agreement
that led to culture and language based
education
and now there are migma children who
have mi'kmaq as their first language
there's so much that we can do these
children are students in the minidumina
singh anishinaabe kinomagemig
an immersion school on manitoulin island
where they learned in anishinaabe moan
they arrived at school in junior
kindergarten speaking very little if any
in the
moon and now in grade three and grade
four
they're testing at intermediate and
fluent levels
at the same time they have beautifully
high self-esteem
they are proud to be anishinabe people
and they have strong learning skills
not all education has to be formal
education either
in our local community we have the
kingston indigenous language nest
kiln is an organization now but it
started six years ago
with passionate community members
gathered around an elder's kitchen table
since then we have created weekend
learning experiences
aimed at multi-generational learning
where we focus on passing language and
culture onto children
we use traditional games songs foods and
activities to do that
we have classes at both the beginner and
intermediate levels
offered right here we've partnered with
school boards and libraries to have
resources and language
in place in formal education that the
possibilities are just
endless and i'm so grateful for the work
that has been done
to allow me to pass language and culture
onto my son and to other children within
our community
we've developed a strong beautiful
vibrant community as well
as a result of this shared effort
so what do we need moving forward
first of all we need policy we need an
active policy
with attached funding that will ensure
that indigenous language is incorporated
meaningfully into
education both on and off reserve on
reserve education is funded at
significantly lower levels than it is
off reserve
an off-reserve indigenous language
education is often neglected because
people assume
that indigenous people are not present
in provincial schools when actually
around 70 percent of indigenous people
in canada today live
off reserve those children have equal
right
to access their language and culture
beyond policy we need support and that
doesn't just mean
financial support we need space where we
can carry out activities
classes and interaction with
non-indigenous populations as well
we need support that looks like people
wanting to learn the language
we need support where people talk about
why these languages are important
and to achieve that we need education we
need access
to immersion education primarily as that
is
most certainly the most effective way to
ensure the transmission of indigenous
languages
but we also need education in provincial
schools we need education for the
non-indigenous population so that we can
come to a better mutual understanding
and move forward in a better way
together
i have this quote hanging in a frame
picture on my office wall it was a gift
from a settler ally student that i
taught a few years ago and it reminds me
every day
that we can achieve great things if we
work together
but if we're going to talk about
reconciliation we need to acknowledge
that a reconciliation that does not
result
in the survivance and continuation of
indigenous languages and cultures
is no reconciliation at all it is
assimilation
and it shouldn't be acceptable to any of
us but what we can do
is look to the calls to action we can
look to the united nations declaration
on the rights of indigenous people and
we can come to a mutual understanding
that what we have in terms of linguistic
and cultural heritage for indigenous
people in this country
is worth saving based on that
we can step forward together
to ensure that indigenous languages are
passed on beyond 2050 beyond the next
generation
into the next seven generations
thank you